here with reaction all of this no
stranger to war zones herself is fox
nation host lara logan lara your take on
today
well sean you know what i didn't hear in
the hearing today i didn't hear an
apology to the afghan people
for the lies that have been told about
them i didn't hear an apology to the
democratically elected president of
afghanistan amrul asala who has not quit
and is still in the fight i didn't hear
an apology to all the american
servicemen the veterans and the active
duty soldiers who have literally stood
shoulder to shoulder with the afghan
special operations forces who are still
fighting today and apologize to them for
dragging them down in the absolute uh
shame of betrayal which is where we are
and you know what else we didn't hear
any mention of what we're gonna do about
it right everybody's acting like this is
over it's some kind of done deal and so
you know we need accountability but what
about we need action to reverse what's
happened now why do we accept as the
american people
that all of these weapons 80 plus
billion dollars of advanced military
hardware has to be in the hands of our
enemies has to be in the hands of
terrorists and has to be in the hands of
our adversaries like china and pakistan
and iran that is not an acceptable
situation it's not okay for general
milly to sit there like a pathetic
little school boy and say yes america's
less safe okay we don't need that from a
general we need a general who's going to
lead that is what we the people are
asking for leaders who are going to lead
and you know what sean they're going to
get accountability we the people are
going to get accountability because it's
their government it's actually their
military and it's actually their
institutions and i want everybody to
know that the president of afghanistan
who is the democratically elected leader
he called me he watched the hearings
today and he called me to offer his
thanks to the american people and to the
congressmen on both sides of the aisle
democrat and republican who had the
courage to stand up for what was right
and to get some degree some tiny little
bit of the truth and he wanted me to
tell you on his behalf that he is very
grateful because he never lost his faith
in the good of what america stands for
and believes in and the other thing that
you should know is that the resistance
that they want to write out of history
right the cia and all the other you know
um information warfare operatives out
there have been very busy pushing their
false narratives that the afghans all
surrendered that you can't buy willpower
thanks general austin you know and so on
well they want you to know that in the
last 48 hours they've killed hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of taliban all
across afghanistan that the fight has
not stopped it's continuing to this day
and that a representative for the
democratically elected government of
afghanistan and its president amritsar
will be present at the united nations in
new york at the general assembly and
they will have something to say at that
meeting and you know one thing sean that
is being left out of this whole
conversation that is the most critical
of all when it comes to what we do
moving forward is pakistan because the
truth is
yes there was corruption in afghanistan
people can point fingers at the
resistance at the taliban and so on and
there's a plenty of blame to go around
right and accountability but this is
what has been true from day one it's the
simplest thing of all about the entire
conflict you cannot defeat an enemy who
isn't in the country that's it
if your enemy is not in afghanistan
there's nothing you can do about that is
there you can't win that fight you have
to go across the border into pakistan
where they actually reside
and you know if we were going to leave
80 billion worth of military equipment
the most sophisticated the latest
greatest best technology on the face of
the earth
maybe we could have left it with the
people that actually wanted to free
afghanistan not the terrorists that now
control uh the blackhawk helicopters and
the drones and the night
vision goggles and the billions of
dollars of equipment lara uh thank you
we still can sean we we have the
capability to change this right now with
thermal uavs and all kinds of other
equipment we don't have to accept this
outcome i wish someone had asked general
milley or general austin how much of our
advanced military capability have we
actually used and they will tell you
it's 10 or less so for goodness sake
what do you got it all for if you're not
going to use it exactly
they're not lifting a finger they've
abandoned our fellow americans they've
abandoned their families they've
abandoned green card holders they've
abandoned our afghan allies and this is
not going to end well
you know it and i know it and i pray to
god i come on the air one day and i get
to say i was wrong
because they'll be safe if i can say
those words
thank you lara logan all right don't
forget lara's show 21st century
terrorism revealed it's blowing up on
foxnation.com i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kilmeade and i'm ainsley earhardt and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis